if i was to come to you three years ago
before covered and say imagine the
government printed 450 billion pounds
and gave it to the rich what do you
think would happen you don't need to be
an economist you say okay well if the
rich get a ton of money they're going to
push the prices up which will be fine
for them because they've got a ton of
money that will hurt the rest of us
right and the rich will start to consume
a larger share of the natural resources
and natural resources become more
expensive for the rest of us that's not
complicated okay that happened it's
obvious it's obvious and that's 450
billion pounds and now richardson like
is on tv saying oh don't worry we stand
by ready to help with five billion
pounds
you give 450 billion pounds to the rich
and then you say we're gonna help with
five billion pounds it's not
it's not gonna it's not going to help
right and then labor cell we're going to
win full tax on oil and gas companies
and we're going to raise 2 billion
pounds these guys are so far out of
touch you know they're playing a
different game you know if you transfer
450 billion pounds to the rich and then
you you take five billion pounds back
you're going to destroy the economy
right
but but who's talking about it listen